I'm a nervous I'm nervous right now my
name is Patty and I am pro-life I had
two abortions I know what happens to the
emotional and psychological part of
women my name is John and I'm pro-choice
six years of the Planned Parenthood my
name is Marie and I am pro-life and I
help women reverse their abortion once
they've started them if they would like
to do so
oh well sandwich is just something
between two pieces of bread and I
disagree and sandwiches two pieces of
bread right but a hot dog bun isn't two
pieces of bread my own game just the way
it's if you had a hot dog bun and you
put likes deli meats in there would that
be still would it be a sandwich that
would still be a hot dog though still
right I mean it's okay are we gonna
solve the whole piece here
oh right yeah because you're the other
person's perspective and you're like
okay that makes sense
yeah no I I think I question mine often
because I could imagine that if I wasn't
living my life based on my Christianity
I would want women to have that choice
as well I used to be a pro-life feminist
yes until I had an abortion actually I
had to and after I realized what I had
done I knew I had made the biggest
mistake in my life I realized that it
was it wasn't my I shouldn't be taking
the life of a child so after that I
struggled with it for 35 years with my
abortions and so I have no doubts I am
all the way pro-life but I believe
fundamentally that the woman should have
that right to make the decision and it's
I've never been anybody who's
pro-abortion and oftentimes they don't
have good choices and they're picking
the lesser of the bad choices yeah I
just feel like my I'm very certain of my
views because I want to respect that
everyone has that option and I think
that if you take that away you endanger
children more than if you allow them to
make that choice for themselves so but a
woman can choose for herself but she
doesn't have the right to choose for
someone else because if if a child is
inconvenient as a toddler are you going
to kill that child as a toddler I think
we're talking about a completely
different thing though in that silence
we're talking science and I'm saying
like a lot of times women have to have
abortions because of medical reasons
that's like a lot of time
right in the thick of it
my sister had an abortion almost two
years ago I found out I was pregnant and
had an abortion forced on me by a man
twice my age
who made a ton of money and I felt like
I had no other choice if I wasn't a
Christian and if I didn't believe the
things that I believed I would be
pro-choice like 100% but at the end of
the day like to my core
I believe that all human life is so
sacred and it's not our choice it's
never been our choice I realized that I
shouldn't have had that choice because I
was choosing life and death over another
human being it's taking a life but I do
understand definitely understand where
you guys came from the only difference
we have is when that comes if that's a
human being then my puzzles I think
there are very great hurry yeah and in
the Bible you didn't say you know I
don't know what part of Christianity but
Jesus says before I formed you in your
mother's womb I knew you not a sparrow
falls from the sky without my knowing I
feel like I really respect you and your
faith I respect that that's your feeling
and I think that you all feel that way
but I also feel like one can feel that
way regardless of the Bible regardless
of Christianity you know it's one of
those things that happens and has
happened actually for decades you know
for a while and people make that
decision and it is their decision they
make that decision for whatever reasons
you know and again you you help people
who have taken a pill first then change
their mind and I think that's great but
if you have one and you feel regretful
then deal with it if you have one you
don't really feel regretful or you feel
like it really truly was the best
decision for you then that's what
happens and I just think we all know
people like that or I'd just don't feel
like we have any right to force a
particular way and and and and you know
I think it's great to try to just be
open you know
one time I think we all feel that way
because because it's an emotional very
emotional topic
I've actually been verbally attacked by
a lot of the pro-choice people you know
about what I went through with the
regret the alcoholism and all of that
stuff that tied into the abortion for me
something that Marie said a little bit
while ago about our Christian faith and
implicit in that is that someone who's
pro-choice isn't Christian I was raised
a Roman Catholic I consider myself a
Christian I don't believe that there's
anything in Christianity because I
understand it that requires me to
believe that abortion is work I grew up
in a Christian home my mom's a pastor
but they also respect that they know
that it's my ultimate decision and they
know that what it is I'm gonna do I'm
gonna choose for my life they don't have
control over and that I am an adult
sometimes in the argument between the
two sides there's a lack of respect for
the fact that like I don't have to agree
with you you live your life the way that
you want you and I'll live the way I
want to as long as you're not stopping
sorry you guys I have two kids one son
is 30 and then a daughter who's 28 I
have one son who is 36 he's adopted I
couldn't have children biologically I
convinced a doctor to give me a tubal
ligation because I didn't feel i
punished myself for having the abortions
I have a daughter she's a year old and
she's in heaven to me my experience at
Planned Parenthood was everybody had
kids and the slogan if you will my
parent it was no child an unwanted child
and we wanted our children and that's
why we chose what about all the people
that would gladly take care of that
child that cannot have a pregnancy to
save their life nine months for a whole
life that a child could have I think one
of the things that I really reacted to
is that okay nine months whatever but
there are so many children not just in
America but the world over that don't
have loving parents that are not in a
loving situation that are not cared for
fed clothes loved and I think that is
the most important thing to care about
our children because they are our future
so the child in the womb has no value
whatsoever no I don't think so at all
I'm not saying that I never said okay
I'm just saying I'm just saying that to
me that's unclear whether it's you know
this or that or this or that and despite
the fact that you say there are people
out there that want to adopt this child
or want to take care of this child there
are still so many there or not and
that's I don't think that wrong makes
this right though I understand that I'm
not saying that I'm only calm Elyria I'm
only respond
to your comment about a bike my view is
I don't I don't personally want to have
kids I want to adopt all my children
because of that reason and because I
lived with a family that took me in when
my family didn't want me and so I
understand that one the foster system
and adoption is not that easy and if
we're making it about taking care of the
child yeah let's do that let's take care
of the children but we need to make sure
that there are opportunities in place
for all the children to be successful so
that that child has a world to come to
come into you it's actually gonna be
good to it because we don't live in that
world right now we don't offer those
things to our children you should talk a
lot of the people that came from a ton
of adversity who've now made it in this
world who were talking about that we're
not talking about the success we happy
about people that I'm a kids or two days
they're not and they're worth that worth
in my opinion is exactly equal to a
twenty week baby and totally understand
and I respect that
I'm only saying my only comment was I
feel like it's unfair to be like well
blah blah blah nine months why can't you
just have a kid for nine months and they
give it up oh it is getting cooler in
here though isn't it
I surprised
I wasn't expecting to hear some of the
stories about people's lives and their
experiences who've had abortions and
like I can only I can only imagine the
pain that is associated to making that
decision and I have a lot of compassion
and sympathy for people who go through
that I wasn't expecting I wasn't
expecting it to be as calm as it was I
think that there were moments but I
think for the most part we were
respectful of each other and I still
think that you guys are awesome people I
mean outside of this situation I wasn't
surprised at how this is gone because
when we were - all talking outside it
didn't make any difference
whose side was on whose side and we and
we all bonded right away you know
sometimes our levels got a little bit
raised but you know where we all respect
each other no matter what you do you've
heard all the arguments there's not
gonna be one argument where you're like
oh my gosh I just changed my mind no
it's never gonna you know people are
they are and it usually takes a certain
situation happening but I think it's
healthy to have the dialogue I think it
doesn't happen enough it happens too
much behind our computers
oh yeah great news
[Music]